en esta presentación vamos a vamos a
aprender cómo graficar funciones
trigonométricas sin tener que graficar
punto por punto y bueno espero que eso
después de esta presentación puedas al
observar una función trigonométricas
puedas averiguar cuál es la definición
analítica de esa función así que
comencemos comencemos digamos que yo
tengo yo tengo que fx fx espero estar
usando todas las herramientas correctas
digamos que fx es igual es igual a 2 a 2
seno de que te gustaría 2 seno de un
medio de x ajam entonces un medio de x y
cuando vemos esto varias cosas
interesantes surgen como bueno con cómo
es esto diferente a la función seno la
regular puedes ver que aquí tenemos
estamos multiplicando por un coeficiente
del coeficiente 2
el ángulo x está x el un medio ahora en
otros vídeos vimos que este término del
2 afecta a la amplitud y el término un
medio afecta el periodo entonces eso que
hay aquí aquí iniciemos con la amplitud
este 2 nos dice que la amplitud de esta
función será 2 bajar porque si fuera
sólo 1 la amplitud sería 1 pero no es 2
así que dibujar una línea bueno dos
líneas punteadas una en que igualados
allí está la línea punteada en igualados
un poco sueca pero se entiende la idea y
otra en menos en lleida -2
ahora bien hay que averiguar sabemos que
sabemos que esta es la amplitud sabemos
que la función oscilará entre estos dos
valores entre estas dos líneas punteadas
pero tenemos que averiguar qué tan
rápido va a oscilar entonces o cuál es
su periodo y para esto te voy a dar una
fórmula para eso debes saber que la
función es igual a la amplitud
multiplicada por digamos la función seno
aunque aunque también puede también
funcionar para la función coseno pero
bueno es un ejemplo solamente la
amplitud de la función por el seno de
dos pies sobre el período x
esto es una p p de periodo y tal vez no
te parezca tan obvio pero pero me
gustaría que qué tal vez después de este
vídeo después de otros vídeos veamos qué
sucede cuando cuando cambiamos este
coeficiente en el término de la equis y
ya aseguró con eso tendrá todo más
sentido así bueno por ahora por ahora
tomemos esto como un acto de fe un acto
de fe
dos pies sobre p es el coeficiente en x
y si decimos que dos pisos pp es igual
al coeficiente en este caso es igual a
un medio
espero nos trate confundiendo pero voy a
poner una línea que separa así así
tenemos que dos pisos sobre p es igual a
un medio entonces un medio por el
periodo es igual a dos pi y entonces el
periodo es igual a 4 pi
y bueno sabemos que la amplitud es igual
a 2 el periodo es igual a 4 pi y lo
repito como como es que nos dimos cuenta
que el periodo es igual a 4 p bueno
usando esta fórmula mágica así fue como
lo hicimos dos pies sobre el periodo es
el coeficiente en el término x y dos
pies sobre el periodo es igual a un
medio después que sucede por dónde
empezamos aquí que es seno de ok que es
f de cero cuando x es igual a cero todo
esto todo este término se hace cero
entonces que es seno de cero seno de
cero es cero eso recuérdalo eso siempre
tengo bien presente seno de cero es cero
o puedes observar el círculo unitario
entonces seno de serón es cero y cero
por 12-0 por lo tanto efe de cero es
igual a cero y ahora bien a ok sabemos
que tiene un periodo de cuatro pi eso
nos dice que la función se va a repetir
después de cuatro pi y entonces se va a
repetir se repetirán de aquí
hasta este punto acá de aquí hasta acá
que es 4 p
entonces ahora podemos dibujar la
función esto nos llevará un poco de
práctica pero pero la dibujo y luego qué
te parece si exploramos un poco la
función oa la gráfica la función se
mirará algo así así algo el mejor
intento luego seguir en la otra
dirección
así seguirán y bueno debes notar que el
periodo aquí va de va de este punto de
este punto de aquí a este punto hasta
este otro punto desde aquí hasta acá esa
es la distancia de 4 pin y eso es lo que
lo que le toma la función repetirse o
pasar por un ciclo también si quieres
podrías medir esta distancia a este otro
punto de este punto hacia otro punto eso
también sería 4 pi y esa es el periodo
ese es el periodo de la función hay de
hecho claro que también a la amplitud de
las funciones 2 a jan es 2
esta es la amplitud luego el periodo de
cuatro pisos resolvimos gracias a esta
fórmula mágica y otra manera de pensar
en esto digamos que voy a voy a borrar
lo que tengo aquí
ajá entonces lo borro pues ya supongamos
que que no sabía no sabía lo que tengo
aquí ok digamos que que no tenía idea de
cuál era la función solo sólo se me dio
como información la gráfica
y se nos pide encontrar la ecuación de
la gráfica usando esta gráfica intenta
averiguar cuál es la función es lo que
se nos pide luego si bueno observas
cuánto cuánto le tomo esta función
repetir se le tomó cuatro operaciones
así que visualmente te puedes dar cuenta
que el periodo de estas funciones 4p
luego te preguntas ok cuál es la
amplitud esto es sencillo de saber
simplemente observas observas cuánto
sube o baja a su vez dos y bueno cabe
mencionar que no vamos a tomar en cuenta
todo esto simplemente la mitad y así que
la amplitud es igual a 2 en este caso el
periodo es igual a 4 pi la amplitud es
igual a 2 luego tu pregunta sería ok
está oscilando es periódica perfecto
pero es una función se nuevo es una
función coseno para la función coseno
asumiendo no no están haciendo ninguna
traslación aquí en otro vídeo haré una
función trasladada pero en este caso
asumimos que que no está trasladada
costello de cero
es igual a 1 cierto y seno de cero es
igual a cero esta función en cero es
cero por lo tanto es una función seno
y usamos de esta fórmula fx es igual a
la amplitud por el seno de dos pi sobre
el periodo x y ahí lo tenemos la función
es igual a fx igual a la amplitud por el
seno de dos pisos sobre el período
y sobre el periodo el cual es 4x y estos
estos se cancelan
y esto se vuelve 2 seno de un medio de x
200 que está un poco difícil de leer
esto pero es momento de hacer una
pregunta cómo se mirará esta función fm
x igual a 2
igualados coseno de un medio x se va se
va a mirar igual pero iniciaremos en
otro punto en un punto distinto que es
coseno de cero coseno de cero cuando x
igual a cero todo este término se hace
se hace cero así que coseno de cero es
igual a uno
entonces coseno de 0 es igual a 1
así que f de 0 es igual a 2 así bueno
entonces voy a dibujar esta función la
función coseno en diferente color
iniciaremos en este punto rosa ene efe
de 0 igual a 1 pero todo lo demás se
queda igual la amplitud es la misma el
periodo es el mismo así que se mirarán
se va a mirar la función algo así y
después bajan
y vuelve a subir pasa por este punto y
otra vez así ahora también en el así del
otro lado es lo mismo sube y todo eso ok
ahora bueno debes notar que las
funciones seno y cosenos se parecen
bastante muchísimo muchísimo y la manera
de diferenciarlas la manera más sencilla
es evaluando las en cero que es ver es
preguntarse qué sucede en el eje de las
10 cuando x es igual a 0 o el ángulo que
se que se pone ahí es 0
al menos que estemos trasladando aunque
bueno no no te preocupes mucho por eso
de la traslación ahora seno de cero es
igual a cero y coste no de cero es igual
a 1 y como lo estamos multiplicando por
este factor el 2 entonces uno por dos
igualados así que esa es la gráfica de
coseno de x y la gráfica de seno de x de
hecho este es como un vídeo de estilo
pre traslación es cierto nota que la
gráfica rosa es muy similar a la gráfica
verde pero solo que está trasladada en
esta dirección en este caso por una
distancia de
y bueno ahí ahí lo tenemos ya se me está
terminando el tiempo pero espero que
haya ayudado bastante esto y bueno ahí
las tiene las funciones de seno de xy la
función del coste no de x pero con esta
amplitud y ese periodo